what if i told you life is filled with
contradictions and i'm gonna give you
one today that you're gonna say
pat this one's confusing but damn i am
so fired up at the end that i want to
take over the world and share this video
with everybody i know and if i'm right
give it a thumbs up subscribe and share
it with people that you know so let me
get right into it this past weekend my
two boys decide to watch batman not only
batman begins not only dark night but
dark night rises and now they want to go
watch the most recent batman they came
out so we're sitting there and i get off
a zoom i come in and we're watching dark
knight rises
and it's the scene with bain
where bruce is stuck in that cave and
they're looking up with all these
prisoners and he can't get out
and he's running running running the guy
puts the rope around him he falls he's
running running running the guy puts the
rope around him they do the chant he
said what's the chant rise rise rise he
falls
so there's this last one that he does
and he's going up that he tries to jump
to grab the cliff grab the other side
and he falls and one of the man says to
him he says just stop trying he says why
don't we stop trying he says you're not
going to do it he said what do you mean
i'm not going to do it he says you're
just not he said but how did the child
do it if the child can do it how come i
can't do it he says there's a big
difference he says what's the difference
he says the child didn't grow up with
the life of luxuries that you did
you grew up with too many luxuries you
don't have to do this the child had
nothing to lose
the child had to get out of this place
because this child didn't have a life of
luxuries and he's like well i'm going to
train i'm going to do this i'm going to
start doing push-ups he starts doing
sit-ups and it's the scene he's doing
sit-ups and i'm going to do this and i'm
going to do this and he goes okay i'm
ready put the rope around him goes up
boom he jumps he falls again he falls
again he's super discouraged
and he's sitting there in the jail
and a man to his left who's blind starts
talking to him and it's one of the most
profound scenes of that entire movie and
here's what he said so the blind
prisoner you're looking at the face of
the blind prisoner says to him
you do not fear death
you think this makes you strong
it actually makes you weak bruce wayne
says why
he says
how can you move faster than possible
fight longer than possible without the
most powerful impulse of the spirit the
fear of death
bruce wayne says i do fear death
i fear dying here while my city burns
and there's no one there to save it
blind prisoner then make the climb
bruce wayne
how
blind prisoner you ready here's what he
says
as the child did
without the rope
then fear will find you again
i'm watching this and i'm like oh my god
i have the chills all over my body i
haven't seen this movie for a long time
some of the messages hit me boom right
and i'm like
oh my god
then you see him going
and he goes and the guy hands him the
rope he says i don't want the rope
rise rise they're doing the chant in
their own language he goes all the way
to the top and it's the jump that he's
got to make
he's so afraid because if he doesn't
make the jump he's going to die so guess
what that fear does to him it makes him
jump in a real way like a real real
effort because he knows
if you don't make the jump it's the fear
of death baby you're gonna die that's
what's gonna happen
he jumps he makes it
climbs goes over
throws the rope over to the prisoners
and he leaves and goes and saves the
city what does this have to do with you
well that message to me is i'm having
this conversation one of our guys george
and a couple of other guys and i'm
saying listen you guys think i'm not
afraid
you don't think i'm afraid
and one of our guys says pat i've seen
you speak from stage i've seen you in a
lot of weird meetings i've never seen
you be afraid i said dude i'm more
scared than you are how could you say
that i said i guarantee you i'm more
scared than you are
i don't understand this part explain it
to us so let me explain to what i mean
by more scared than you are
so i'll unpack it for you so
i'm 23 years old single
and relationships not working out and i
asked a weird question because i wanted
to get married i'm like i'm not ready i
said would you let your daughter marry a
23 year old like you today i said no way
okay
so why don't you
realize if you don't do something about
your life your daughter is probably
going to marry a guy like you because
she's going to settle
do you know what that does to me that
fear i can't even tell you what that
fear does to me there is no way my
daughter is going to settle my
daughter's going to marry somebody that
she loves that's her choice she may
settle with a guy but it's not because
of her daddy it's going to be her choice
that created a level of urgency where
i'm going going going going i'll give
you another crazy one you're going to
think i'm crazy but i'm being open with
you and transparent with you you know
this whole idea about sleepovers that
americans do like hey well let's go do a
sleepover i don't like sleepovers
there's only one house you're going to
sleep over it's my house i wouldn't do
no sleepovers at your house
pat that's that's kind of con your
country hypo it's not kind of like a
hypocrite just let me explain to what i
mean by this i sat there and i said
i want to have a place where my friend
my kids friends come to our place
because i can trust if you're going to
come to our place and i'll set it up
nice safe and everything security and
everything because i'm paranoid because
i was born and raised in iran and in
iran we were afraid of what they're
going to do to your kids that fear
makes me work double time to have that
place to provide that privacy and
security to my kids sounds weird but
that fear created urgency i'll give you
another fear one of my biggest fears
maybe all the way at the top and this
one this one would get me emotional at
any time you know i fear my dad dying
i fear my dad dying without my kids
meeting my dad oh my god that that gets
me very emotional i was so afraid of my
dad dying without my kids meeting him
and have a relationship with him because
i don't have a relationship with his dad
my grandpa died when i was born never
met this man
so i said okay what happens if dad dies
working on a 99 cent store stressed out
because he doesn't have the money that
created such a level of urgency and that
fear got me to move where you know where
my dad lives right now first floor of my
house you know how fun i see him right
now every time i'm home he's got his
room by the water on the water he does
whatever he wants and i'm very happy but
that fear drove me i can't go on it with
how are you such a capitalist it's based
on fear
based on me wanting to stay free and my
kids staying free so going back to you
um
obviously this is a movie
but you have your own cave you're living
in you got your own cave
you got your own cave
and you keep trying to escape this cave
but you keep using that rope
and you don't realize it's the reason
why you're not getting out that rope is
the number one do you see how emotional
this is you you know what that rope is i
know you know what that rope is we can't
get out of this cave
it's a limiting belief it's a little
insurance policies what if
what if i get fired what if i get this
and it's holding you back and you ain't
giving your best at your company at the
job at the whatever you're doing because
you're afraid what if so you don't
commit what if marriage what if
relationship what if this
it's the rope
that prisoner the blind prisoner's right
and it's holding you back so
what do you got to do be afraid again
start being scared
be more scared
that if you die
and it's just a regular life
25 people show up to your funeral
and then a year later a couple people
show up five years later nobody ever
comes to your plot ever again and you're
forgotten that's scary
that should scare the [ __ ] out of you if
you think about it though because that
scares the crap out of me
scares the crap out of me i don't think
the man upstairs put me here
to just play small neither you so like i
told you
this is a heavy message
if you felt the message and you're
willing to receive it give it a thumbs
up subscribe to the channel and share
this message and feeling with people
around you because maybe this message is
exactly what they need to hear and the
video i recommend you to watch is a
message i gave probably a month ago or
so on the message of will versus want if
you've not seen it
it has a lot to do with exactly what i
just talked about in this video click
here to watch that video take care
everybody bye bye bye
you